breaking news it is the moment we have
now been anticipating for a long time on
this show equal justice equal
application of our laws Lieutenant
General Michael Flynn he was a war hero
he served this country honorably and
with distinction with multiple tours of
duty in Iraq and Afghanistan he put
himself in harm's way for our freedom
and our way of life 33 years of total
service he was unfairly and justly
targeted by deep state bureaucrats that
clearly with all the evidence now to
prove it
wanted to take him down we have newly
unsealed documents that prove that
corrupt agents from Jim Comey's FBI
we're discussing strategies on how to
set general Flynn up on what we call a
perjury trap and according to one
handwritten note an unnamed agent ass
well what is our goal here is a truth
admission or to get him to lie to get
him to lie is that our goal so we can
prosecute him or get him fired is that
the FBI's role and get this in an email
Peter struck and his FBI lover Lisa page
they discussed how to casually slip in
an admonition about lying under oath in
order to set a stronger perjury trap
these agents were preparing for an
interview that ultimately did take place
on January the 24th 2017 day for the
Trump administration truth be told it
was an ambush it was a legal abuse of
power corrupt ambush now remember during
a phone call it was deputy FBI director
McKay be recommended that Flynn hi oh
you don't need to have an attorney
present during the interview that would
have been a Miranda rights violation
four days after president Trump's
inauguration Peter struck one other
agent they visited the White House and
they were there to interrogate Flynn
they were sent in by Jim Comey himself
James Comey bragging remember he sent
the agents to grill Flynn just four days
in the administration he wanted to
exploit the chaos inside the
transitioning White House something he
would never do in the bush or Obama
administration's or stration or get away
with ultimately that perjury trap was
not a success agents saw no indication
at all
that the National Security Advisor was
lying I didn't believe he was lying they
said they didn't believe he was lying
commis FBI turned the screws anyway they
threatened to lock Flynn up for years he
eventually went bankrupt he had to sell
his home they threatened to prosecute
his son they ultimately forced him to
plead guilty get this guilty plea making
him a felon for the rest of his life or
they were going to prosecute his son
they didn't think he lied but then they
forced him to lie coerced him into
making statements why to protect his son
now frankly what great father wouldn't
do that well either you sign this so
we're gonna put your son away for the
rest of his life where do I sign Flynn
was set up it was a perjury trap all
along now commis FBI knew the rush of
collusion narrative they knew it was a
hoax and we have new information
regarding that they were hell-bent on
punishing anyone and everyone inside the
Trump administration by the way mr.
Comey I've been warning you you have the
right to remain silent
I've suggested you use it you've not
listened to me Jim tick tock now keep in
mind we've been right every step of the
way the media mob what have they been
doing they have lied they had advanced
hoaxes after hoax conspiracy theory
after conspiracy theory state-run
so-called news channels oh and the
socialist paper Pravda record of record
in the United States the New York toilet
paper times take a look this is week one
of the trump presidency is in the name
of Jim Comey's book a higher loyalty
wouldn't that be to the United States
Constitution
the rule of law equal justice under the
law does that sound like a virtuous
public servant to you or someone trying
to trap lieutenant general Flynn from
day one page after page after page of
evidence corrupt agents like McCabe
instruct and call me and others were
conspiring to set Lieutenant General
Flynn up and ruin his life and by the
way this is exhibit
of a corrupt bureaucracy that is a
threat to everything we hold dear our
Republic is now and I'm not overstating
this that we are facing a clear and
present danger America is at a tipping
point we have a very important election
in 188 days now to the credit of the
Attorney General of the United States
Bill Barr the Attorney General he's been
leaving these little crumbs here there
and everywhere and if you listen to what
he's saying oh the president was spied
on candidate was spied on he's made
other statements like yeah no this is an
this is not about writing a paper
meaning the durum investigation this is
about justice this my sources tell me
tonight is all happening because the
Attorney General believes in the rule of
law by the way I have an FBI pin here
and I have a CIA pin here why for the
99% that do a great job and protect us
every day we must restore confidence in
our premier law enforcement agency the
premier or agency in the world the
premier intelligence agency in the world
for the sake of our constitution for the
sake of the 99% of people who bravely
serve these institutions and protect us
and thanks to the president and his
attorney general bill Barr this deep
state reckoning is going on right before
our eyes it's sad to see but at least
people believe in the law this is not
how we should be treating a 33 year
devoted veteran who loves his country
and his son this is not the last shoe to
drop